[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
assurance emprunteur le sénat a enrichi
la proposition de loi
vous prévoyez d'acheter une maison mais
vous craignez que votre état de santé ne
vous empêche de solliciter un emprunt
bancaire
le sénat a obtenu des avancées majeures
pour faciliter l'accession à la
propriété des personnes ayant souffert
de pathologies dans le cadre de l'examen
de la proposition de loi concernant
l'assurance emprunteur sur laquelle
députés et sénateurs ont trouvé un
compromis le 3 février 2022
le questionnaire médical qui empêche
bien souvent les anciens patients de se
lancer dans un nouveau projet de vie est
ainsi supprimée pour les prêts
immobiliers inférieur à 200 mille euros
en outre le délai du droit à l'oubli
pour les pathologies cancéreuses et
l'hépatite c est réduit de 10 à 5 ans
le sénat contre l'avis initial du
gouvernement
ainsi concrétiser la promesse de
campagne du président de la république
sur le plan de la concurrence le
compromis consacre également un droit de
résiliation à tout moment des contrats
d'assurance emprunteur
mais élargir le droit à résiliation sans
renforcer l'information des assurés
aurait été un coup d'épée dans l'eau
conformément au souhait du sénat les
assureurs devront donc les informer
chaque année de l'existence de ce droit
et de ses modalités de mise en oeuvre
reste maintenant à l'assemblée nationale
et au sénat a adopté définitivement ce
texte majeur qui permettra de mettre fin
un grand nombre de situations très
injuste
l'examen en séance publique au sénat est
prévue le jeudi 17 février 2022 et sera
diffusée en direct sur notre site
internet
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse des travaux du sénat sur la
proposition de loi
[Musique]